because um
welcome to Scandinavia it's a pleasure
to be here thank you and it's it's
incredible because we all know these
unique harmonies which is what BG's are
most famous for perhaps and and I always
wondered how it would how are you you
sound when you talk well I don't talk in
harmony but then I found quite normal he
did a competition on the BBC one that I
was going down I was in the car and I
was listening to it on the radio I just
turned it on and was it they were there
was trying to find out who the best
harmony sounding groups where they
played the Beatles of Beach Boys they
played Bee Gees and it said we want the
ending was but the the and the reason
that they had these voice specialist
song you know is quite the radio for is
serious serious channel by any stretch
and so it was academic so they were so
trying to analyze why there certain
house but we're better and that
conclusion was they the reason they
thought how's it better because were
brothers
of course the Beach Boys are brothers -
so you didn't explain that one but your
brothers and we were there for sorts of
natural heart we're very close in vocal
tone and however them it's does it
doesn't explain of me there are pros but
nice to have won the competition
whatever was little victories but can't
can you and Barry still sing like this
oh yeah of course I would the star why
would why would they but I don't know
what happens you know Oh course gonna
say oh nice it actors don't stop acting
but the thing is that you you
cherry-pick with your other it's we're
composers as well as being singers and
oh our Korea has been and we started out
as composing and we've written for
Barbra Streisand and islands in the
stream for Kenny Rogers no Parton
you can like Diana Ross chain reaction
and things and words ronan keating and
emotion for Beyonce and their woman in
love of course which you started that as
well as a heartbreaker for Dionne
Warwick as well so we've had a two-tier
kind of career it hasn't all we've
always put ourselves as composers first
and musicians and performers there's a
second real in a way because we think
we've got we've got the most successful
song catalog in the world
Lexington lemon Mackay in the world
today in other words that's the most
play catalog in the world including
United States the thing about these
songs is that they can still fill the
floor I mean the songs from from mid 70s
late 70s how do you fill the floor
dancing you know it's crystallized the
thing is what we actually pioneered a
lot of those those sounds where you have
at that trance-like quality on the drums
and we had a more sonic feel to it
incidentally staying alive is the
official paramedic song in America now
poor CPR is true it's been sanctified by
Washington nothing to do with me
I didn't call it Washington say make it
right you know that song
for example brings back to me it brings
back a lot of memories me being a young
man on the summer camp on the long road
you know standing with the girls trying
to make up these noodles to them
yourself
nope I'm not dancer so it's fun right I
usually never tried this dig me see much
yeah but there's always being dance
music it's just the fact is you know
there are people who will down some
people a composer I've never thought the
idea of dancing on stage I think she got
to be a one thing or the other I think
people who tried to do 3 or 4 different
things is a bit like doing this you know
you don't expect a painter to go onstage
and repaint his paint
now go repaint he go onstage on tour now
and repaint or Norfolk he doesn't read a
breed his book on stage when he's got a
new book out or all the director going
to read remake his film on stage and you
actually you had Travolta doing that job
yes so but that was his job yes he
didn't make it because this music it
wasn't originally as I understand
written for Travolta no it wasn't
written no told us true and I wonder is
he as grateful as he should be
I saw with John Travolta last weekend in
Berlin and he's a lovely man and he's
he's always maintained this childlike
sort of quality which is very very
inviting and for me he can't you can't
before I he's a wonderful actor and and
he's he deserves everything that good
that happens that comes his way but to
say grateful is kind of a bit by
patronizing but obviously yes I think
people have listened to you music stop
the committing suicide people who are
gonna commit suicide the music comes on
radio and the lyrics can sometimes tell
and it has happened where armies are of
each color ends and people the star
music sprawl people out of comas people
get buried to our music they get married
to it too as well it's a new hymns I saw
somebody l told you getting married -
how do you put your luck the other day
and they were using the record in the
church so which which Bee Gees - no
would you choose for your funeral thank
you tragedy perhaps actually these days
there there is there is barium and you
and and that's the BG's because yes with
film no but as a B G will be the B G
will cherry pick what we want to do
because we do things because we want it
but we can we can do things we want to
do now as the Bee Gees you know we're
always going to be the gig brothers we
created the name of the Bee Gees because
it was very easy when we were kids this
sort of come up with a name that was
initials of your brothers yeah it wasn't
quick and easy and a disc jockey
Bill Gates name doesn't miss his
initials - but that's when we're about
eight or nine so that was going to be
like a temporary thing how has teen
things changed now that the other
Maurice has gone and also Andy well the
important thing about that things
changed between you and there was never
actually part of the bgz because we
wrote the songs for him as well but me
and Barry have always been the
architects and sound and as the
songwriters at the main force in the
group and still art they ain't in terms
of the whole look of the group although
we didn't really have a design we we
created all the songs and and had the
the ear for what was what was gonna work
Maurice was great Winnie as a keyboard
player and obviously as a singer is why
in certainly of high harmonies but each
player a row of chords on our keyboard
and he would inspire me and buried come
on and will you and Barry get nostalgic
when you listen to
no I don't believe in astrology only be
even good and bad I think today and
tomorrow yeah I'm very proud of our
history that's so it's great but I love
and I love detain tomorrow because it's
all we have and you can't put time in
the bank and you can be you can use it
up you can use it up too much by trying
to remember but the thing is you know
it's it's it's we've had so many close
share I've lost lost I've lost Morris
we've lost handy that's my father
all in like 12 years period so you can't
really think about it sort of putting
things off until tomorrow you know what
we have so much time in this world and
it's not that if you live to be a
hundred it's not a long time and if
you've got something you want to do just
do it and if you think somebody's good
or you love somebody to tell them and
also then praise somebody to think
they're good because that could be the
encouragement
speaking about nostalgia you have been
working with as you mentioned earlier
Celine Dion yes
dyrus Dolly Parton lollipop yeah Barbra
Streisand yes and and who was who would
you say it was the most high main
skating on thin ice here I all the all
high maintenance because the world got
heavy years were all boring and all high
maintenance but I think that the
difficult probably was the one that said
was Dinah Ross where she refused
we had the album finished and we didn't
all the songs but no we didn't hear you
hear a single so me and Barry went back
to the house and we wrote chain reaction
on the last night of the ride because we
said to each other what do you think
well she's one of the soul was one of
Supremes that let's write a song like
The Supremes would do if they were
together so as you know this silver so
we wrote chain reaction words our name
played it to the fine day and she's oh
no I can't do that I can't do a song
that does the streams I think yes that's
why we did it so you can say well I kind
of a big girl babe well cuz I'm what we
say no really no it's a tribute because
you were The Supremes not the only or
whoever else you are you know symbolic
Oh Oh in that case I'll do it
all the you say you get more flies with
honey and what about Kerala I know
you've worked with kuru love the Swedish
yes
famous senior absolutely twenty-five
years ago that's right both Morrison
myself and how is she oh she was great I
had for her for her age she was very
young
she's very professional good great charm
and she she knew very almost you know
she didn't act like she was new to the
business even though she was having
tremendous success and she was very
professional to work with it was she
made a great impression on and she's a
great friend of this show as well and so
we we called her up and she she wanted
to meet you again oh great and good boy
so she's on her way and I'm gonna say
something you know each other